welcome to cbs this morning we begin
with dramatic video
highlighting the often terrible risks of
human trafficking
a suspected smuggling vessel packed with
people ran aground yesterday
near san diego more than two dozen
suspected migrants were aboard the
40-foot boat
and four people died rescuers acted
quickly to save some of the passengers
from downing
drowning lily luciano is in san diego
outside one of the eight hospitals
treating the injured
lilia good morning good morning to you
anthony
27 people were taken to area hospitals
like this one with a wide variety of
injuries including hypothermia
from the frigid water border patrol say
they believe this was a human smuggling
incident
and that cases like this are on the rise
dramatically
they also say the boat's captain is in
custody
this is all that's left of the 40-foot
cabin cruiser after it crashed into a
reef and broke apart sunday morning
ship kind of capsized we saw people
jumping in off-duty navy sailor kale foy
happened to be nearby with his family
and says his military training kicked in
when he jumped in the water to help
we pulled everybody that we could
whether conscious or unconscious
everyone was panicking everyone was
yelling no one spoke any english
brittany kokenderfer shot this video of
the boat shortly after it capsized
you can see at least one person
attempting to flee the vessel by jumping
ship
we were trying to yell and all the
people on the shore were like jump off
jump off you know you got to get out of
that boat
multiple agencies responded to aid the
wounded not only pulling victims from
the water but conducting a cliff rescue
as well
there are people in the water drowning
getting sucked out the rip current there
there's people on shore
reports for cpr in progress down below
with multiple people injured
this was a mass rescue operation that
turned into a mass casualty incident
a border patrol official says there's
every indication that this was a
smuggling vessel
apprehensions of those crossing the
border illegally by sea were up more
than 90 percent last year
and officials say they're seeing a
similar increase this year as well
brittany says she wanted to record what
was happening in case they were
undocumented migrants
people are really risking their lives to
come into this country and
we just wanted to advocate that that
shouldn't be happening
brittany told me she posted this video
in an effort to raise awareness about
the importance of human rights
and the need for immigration reform if
the people on the boat
are in fact undocumented it's still
unclear how enforcement law enforcement
will act and how quickly officials did
say that the boat was different and
bigger than what's
usually used for human smuggling perhaps
in an effort to avoid
being detected gail thank you very much
lilia